نتحدث اولا عن السوداني
الذي شهدناه خلال الايام العشر الماضيه في
السودان
يحطم القلوب هذه الدوله التي يعاني فيها
شعبها اصلا وانا الكثير للسنوات القليله
الماضيه منظمه الصحه العالميه ترحب بوقف
اطلاق النار هذا الاتفاق يتوصل عليه الى
الطرفان ونحط كافه الاطراف على الالتزام
به بالكامل
ان العنف
اثر بشكل كبير على الصحه حلاوه على اعداد
الوفيات والاصابات الناجمه عن النزاع نفسه
فان منظمه الصحه العالميه تتوقع
اكثر بكثير بتفشي
وان توفر المياه والخدمات الصحيه من ضمنها
اللقاحات او التحسين
تقدر صحه العالميه بان ربع الحيوانات التي
زهقت الان كان بالامكان انقاذها مع
امكانيه الوصول
الى العنايه الطبيه الى ان الممرضين
والاطباء غير قادرين الوصول الى المدني
المصابين
والمصابين بدورهم غير قادرين الوصول الى
الخدمات في العاصمه الخرطوم
61% من مشاه الصحيه مغلقه
فقط سته عشر بالمئه تعمل في الوضع الطبيعي
عدد كبير من المصابين من اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه مثل امراض الكبد والسكري والسرطان
غير قادرين على الوصول الى المنشات الصحيه
او الحصول على الادويه التي هم بحاجه
اليها في الاسابيع المقبله
نقدر 24 الف امرا ستلد على ان هنا غير
قادره على الوصول الى الرعايه الان
حتى برامج لمنعه فشي الملاريا اخرى
اضطرت ليتوقف ان مخاطر عالي جدا حيث تاثرت
معنا اللميع وبدا الاشخاص يشربون مياه
الانهار من اجل البقاء مع برامج التقب
برامج الغذاء
خمسين الف طفلا يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه كما
ان حركه المدنيين الباحثين عن الماوى
الامن يؤثر على منظومه الصحيه عبر السودان
منذ اندلاع النزاع ومنظمه الصحه العالميه
تاكدت من سته عشر هاجما على المشعه الصحيه
وتسببت بوفاه ثمانيه اشخاص منظمه الصحه
العالميه قال يقاما
الاستيلائي على المركز الصحي المركزي من
قبل احد الطرفين والفنيين ما قادروا ما
عادوا قادرين على الوصول الى المختبر وهذا
يعني بانه غير قادر على اداء واجباتي
ومهامي التشخيصيه نحن قلقون ايضا من هؤلاء
الذين استولى على المختبر ربما يتعرضون
بشكل غير متعمد على
العينات المخزونه فيها نحن نسال الحصول
المعلومات ونقيم المخاطر
وانقطع الكهرباء تهدد بانما تبقى من
التبرعاتي
منظمه العالميه
يجازف مضافها من اجل توفير الخدمات
لمن هم بحاجه ماسه اليها نحن نعيد تموقع
موظفينا
وعالاتهم من اجل سلامتهم ولكننا مستمرون
بالتخطيط لتقديم خدماتنا على افضل وجه
منظمه الصحه العالميه لديها مخزون من
الادويه
والتبرعاتيه
بالدمعيات الجراحيه ولكننا بحاجه الى وصول
امن من اجل القيام بذلك
وكما هو الحال دائما فان افضل دواء في هذه
الحاله هو السلم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو
ثائق الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات